okay everybody welcome to the Thursday
November 21st 2019 session in our series
about edge computing and I'm Richard -
or I direct the u.s. Asia Technology
Management Center at Stanford we're very
happy to produce this series and we want
to say thanks to the member companies
and our industry affiliates program for
providing this support that let us keep
going thanks to our member companies
we've got some refreshments out back at
the end of the session we hope you'll
stay around meet our speakers meet each
other as at after the end of the formal
part of the program so today we have
another use case for edge computing
right we had talked about some enabling
technologies in several of the sessions
so far last week remember we had leap
mind from Tokyo by live video conference
and that they have a software stack to
enable edge computing in a wide variety
of applications we had also looked at
autonomous vehicles and we had also
looked at medical data where it's a
totally different motivation for using
edge computing as opposed to cloud
computing so today we're going to talk
about augmented reality and virtual
reality I'm delighted that we've got
exactly the right people for this
presentation so our first speaker is
going to be de Jong Pawnee grinding who
is the co-founder and CEO of grid raster
and Digium has a rich experience of over
16 years in building and deploying and
taking to market various mobile and
network based products before founding
grid raster he worked at Texas
Instruments Freescale Semiconductor and
HCl he's really leading the business
development product marketing and
partnership at grid raster and he'll
tell us more about what grid masters do
next
or closest to me is Don Angelo DJ is
senior director in the
emerging technologies team for Charter
Communications as such he's providing
strategic leadership and direction on
service delivery innovation over the
network for new use cases such as cloud
gaming AR and VR he has led the product
team at Time Warner Cable smart home
service and he's had various engineering
roles at Emerson Eton and Bosch before
joining the cable broadband industry so
as you see this covers a couple of
pieces that we really needed to have
covered in the series this fall
not only this use case but also from the
standpoint of the telecom company right
the communication side how we're going
to give this to the network so without
further ado let me turn over the
microphone to Dijon and ask you to give
us your comment thank you for yours and
we can just go down just before I start
like how many of you have tried the
augmented reality and virtual reality
just a show of hands okay
okay and how many of you wish that the
device that you're trying is something
as easy as like a plus you just pick it
up and where you actually see the most
immersive Ness that you see in the bulky
ones right now yeah so I think there's a
long way before we kind of do that and
does it there's a big role that the
cloud and in specifically the edge
computing would be playing to make that
reality happen so a little bit about me
like and the idea the genesis of the
company grid raster how did we kind of
come to form this we have been working
in the space of network and mobile for
the last 15 years have been through the
the first tool core processors
some of the defining technologies in 3G
and 4G and not only like from a deep
engineering aspects point of view but
over a time period I have more into
product and have taken some of this
products into the market across
different geographies during during
actually the world in our previous role
we started getting getting the
requirements for augmented reality and
virtual reality almost like five and six
years back when we are talking about
enabling this whole 5g network and some
of the and at that time like also well
at that time also what we see is there
are other technologies which was kind of
evolving which will ultimately kind of
converge to kind of make certain things
happen the way we the things are shaping
up today one of one of the thing was the
GPUs the GPUs the advancement in the
GPUs was making it possible to do the
kind of compute or the the the
processing that you specifically
required for augmented reality and
virtual reality also the with the advent
of the you know 4G LTE then there is
outlook towards the 5g the data pipes
were beginning to become thicker and
thicker but the problem what we kind of
realized was the attempt took have those
experiences on a mobile device which is
in a form factor or which is which is
confining in the sense that you can't
put active coolant over there there
can't you can only have somewhat of the
GPU that you can cram into those kind of
devices was it was a big deterrent when
it come to proliferating this
experiences across a mainstream use
cases or taking it enabling and enabling
much sleeker designs which people can
kind of wear and from the work that we
were doing we got some insights around
like how can we make use of the remote
computer which in this case which we
started coming as h compute that you are
able to offload the computer intensive
tasks on to the room
with server and be able to still deliver
very very high-end experiences on aced
untether
mobile device and with those insights
actually we started the company grid
roster and we have come a long way out
there but before I delve into what
exactly we do at grid raster I want to
touch upon a little bit around on edge
computing because this is this this edge
computing has become in loaded tongue in
the sense like people conveniently use
the term a based on like what suits them
not that anybody is wrong there but just
that I just want to set the context in
that when I'm talking of edge computing
I'm talking in a certain context well
whoever irrespective of whoever you ask
one thing that is common like everybody
would agree that the fact that you're
moving the compute closer to the user or
the place where the data is kind of
generic get getting generated is what is
term as edge computing and that that
compute you're placing it if you go to
your device manufacturer they would say
ok it's all about the edge is the device
edge because they're trying to put on
the sensors you're trying to put some
compute so that you can do lot of those
processing analytics on that device on
the device itself if you go to the
network players they will talk about the
network edge because on the base station
they're putting the compute and they're
going to term that as their edge but
when we talk in our context when we talk
of edge computing is the first hop from
the end device so it's the first hop on
which we'll be offloading the compute
from the from the device is what we as a
company and in general the community
kind of beliefs
why is this like wow what is the need of
this whole edge computing like the cloud
was working fine what's what happened
nice so there was fundamentally the the
to sifts that was kind of happening one
it's it's the data and it's not the data
just the way we know it it's about the
first time in the history that we
started capturing the real world data in
such a massive amount that it was just
impossible to put that onto the network
so and take it all the way to the cloud
and start processing it so for example I
just took em if you talk of him
self-driving car a self-driving car
in a day generates almost like 4 TB of
data are you gonna put getting it on to
the cloud that's that's not gonna happen
it's not going to be supported if you
actually go into the smart factory where
the factories are designed on the
industry photo you are looking at three
Penta byte of data in a smart factory
kind of scenario that's like humongous
that's humongous and and the other thing
is that you're trying to the the second
aspect which was there not only that you
are generating this massive amount of
data but the the actions of the value
that you're trying to drive from this
data has to be done real-time otherwise
the value kind of goes like in a
autonomous vehicle if I am going to
using one computer
I want to detect there's a stop sign the
car has to stop the decision has to be
taken there you can't just put it there
back to the cloud and take a decision
that that doesn't work so in case of
like augmented reality virtual reality
you're talking about like you're moving
your head and the whole scene what being
rendered being rendered within the sub
20 millisecond if you're trying to do
that you just can't put it to the
centralized cloud and try the process
and we render and just get that done
that's not going to happen
the need the the the massive amount of
data that's been kind of put into the
network by this all the sensors the IOT
even all the cameras that's something
which was one of the reason that kind of
dryer drove this change towards
the edge computing and second thing the
the requirement to kind of process this
in real time where you almost have
minimal latency like ultra-low latency
is something which kind of drove this
whole change or the movement towards the
edge computer so what what are you going
to see now because all this whole edge
computing you you're going to see the
network and it could the whole computer
infrastructure is going to evolve in a
sudden way and what you're going to see
is going to be hierarchy of compute so
you'll have the compute so all all the
compute nodes who like a habit relevance
depending on a use case depending on the
task that you're been down depending on
a certain use case but what you're going
to see is a hierarchy of compute the
cloud is going to still play a major
role but you're going to see the compute
that is on the device the compute that
is on the on the base station the
compute that is on the edge data centers
which was being bailed out is going to
have a role and each of them are going
to be used in a very specific way
depending on the different use cases and
the mostly the mostly the it would be a
it'll be a case that you're trying to
see whether you are trying to adjust to
the latency or whether you're trying to
address the cost it's going to be a
trade-off between both of that and based
on those use cases you're trying to now
orchestrate you're trying to build
efficiency in the network and then kind
of deliver different experiences so the
I think some of the benefits are pretty
sulfide everyday you know you're moving
the compute closer to the user so you're
getting much much faster response you're
avoiding the data overall on the data
hauling over the or the core network
which which doesn't do the network
congestion and that is directly related
to the overall cost reduction because
the transport cost of all the Samanas of
data is going to be like huge secondly
the the for thing is there is going to
be a improvement of the data security
like just for take the example of a
hospital-like there are certain data you
never want to kind of put it out onto
the onto the cloud like there are
patient data that could be kind of just
be processed wood needs to be processed
at the edge right at the hospital but
there are some inferences or certain
learnings that can actually go to the
cloud so there's a whole structure
that's going to be kind of build out
which helps you kind of having a better
see data security and compliance with
the regulations that are in place and of
course the better quality of service
you're getting you'll get much more
predictable predictable latency because
you're looking at minimizing the number
of hops that will be required to do
things in the network so that that's
that's going to be a huge asset coming
together so what is that we are doing
how this whole edge computing and
everything is trying to kind of how you
know a RvR move forward
okay so Idris - what what we are
building is is a cloud platform which
which would be deeply kind of be using
this whole concept on the benefits of
the edge computing and the 3d vision
based iai to enable you to build very
highly scalable platform so where you
can run you know and any number of use
cases across different location you can
scale number of users you can scale your
entire virtual world so we are building
that aspect and I'm somebody like
completely sold on this we completely
believe that the AR VR is going to
completely transform that we the way we
do our work how we live the way we
interact with the world how do we
entertain ourselves like how do we
communicate it's going to completely be
a change and the work that is a long way
to go so we have seen the evolution of
mix reality I just wanted to touch upon
like how things have kind of emerged and
where we are and where we will be in may
be sooner than later so at the beginning
you saw very rudimentary experiences
right so you you saw you know maybe a
Pokemon go where there's a very
rudimentary experiences
you were kind of overlaying certain
specific things on a on a on the real
world you you you have seen the the I
don't know if you've seen the IKEA app
which allows you to kind of get your
furniture you take your house and kind
of drag it out drag your furniture and
put it and kind of replace it and so
that you can plan your whole setting
like how you want to kind of design it
but whatever sudden done they were
pretty rudimentary and most of them was
on the mobile so it was kind of done
just but it was but it was an excellent
way where people kind of got introduced
to that concepts today we have come like
further than that we can create some
sort of Kelley presence where you could
report it to a different wall and you
feel that you are there and also you
will see that we are able to create some
kind of visualizations right
I can I like in the industry they're
doing is the CAD models which they were
initially kind of working on the
workstations now you are actually able
to have those models right in front of
you in in full high fidelity and just
walk around it as if they are like
physically there in front of you but
whatever whatever we have done till now
you still have there's a clear
demarcation between ok here is the
virtual world and here is the real world
ok that demarcation is completely Derek
ok what we are moving towards is where
you will you will completely that the
distinction between the virtual and the
real will kind of go away anyway so the
the virtual the the virtual world will
be overly in such am in the physical
world that it will be almost be
indistinguishable ok and from there from
a technical aspect we are talking about
reaching at like 16 K resolution then
120 frames per second there there are
other things and the ability to overlay
them at absolute in a millimeter
precision so all that those technical
aspects were kind of addressing but but
this is not going to be possible the
kind of the technical requirements are
there to do that it's not going to be
possible
using the clock and we see that
ultimately all devices will converge
where cloud will all the same device
will provide you the a our experience
and possibly VR will be a mode within it
where you switch to a VR mode and you
have VR experiences so it's so while we
believe that's going to happen okay and
but this is this this only be able to be
pervasive which goes to everything and
start having mainstream as I mentioned
before as long as those devices is
mobile and untethered
okay and but today I mean to cram in
those kind of compute and battery
requirements like it's almost good or
almost going to be like 100x compute or
higher computer that will be required to
reach there there then what we have
today on the device so in order to do
that you you basically have to fall back
on on where would that extra compute
would come from and that's where so
that's where grid raster kind of come in
so what what essentially we do is we
have been able to build a platform that
would be able to offload all the compute
intensive tasks right the heavy
rendering okay the 3d world
reconstruction the the 3d AI when you're
doing is semantic analysis of the
different objects that's there in the
scene and you're trying to find the
relationship with each object with each
other and also with the physical world
so all this all this compute intensive
tasks we have been able to kind of
offload to the cloud which in this case
we're talking of the edge cloud and
there are certain certain aspects even
within the rendering that you can
actually upload to a to the cloud like
the global lighting and a global
lighting has a much higher latency
budget so even if it's like 200
milliseconds away the cloud is 200
millisecond away you still be okay to
kind of when the experience will be okay
from a user point of view so we so we
have been able to kind of distribute
this
different compute tasks under different
nodes and bring them together in such a
way that from a user point of view
they're looking at absolutely fully
immersive experiences and without the
constrain off of the device computer so
apart from the fact that we are able to
distribute the compute and be able to do
that there's so many other technical
challenges we need to address to make
this experience possible like how do you
how do you deliver this on a wireless
network like an wireless network known
to be pretty finicky how do you take
care of that how do you decide what
tasks to be distributed where it's all
dynamically like how are you doing going
to do that how do you schedule do those
tasks so all those problems is what we
kind of addressing at grid raster and
kind of working with some of the large
companies and intelligent telecom and
large enterprises in aerospace
automotive to evolve the product and we
continue to do that this is just just
from a little deeper like architecture
in terms of what we are trying to do as
is that the core pieces that we're
trying to do is on the rendering the 3d
ai and the 3d world reconstruction but
having said that like these are still
these are the core technology but in
order for us to kind of put that
together in such a way it's kind of
usable there is a lot that you need to
do around it the first thing is we
beyond the core tech what we have been
able to build as we kind of product eyes
the whole technology is the ability that
you can actually have different kind of
devices like people are going to have
different devices ok you can't really
control who is just what device so if we
with our architecture what is going to
happen is whether you want to use an
Android you're like a hololens or you're
an oculus quest you should be easily
using it through pretty easy API
integration and same thing on the
content side so when we you in the
consumer in the consumer domain most of
the content that you would see today is
you ready based but if you go to the
industrial you have different like Katya
models you have Autodesk you have PTC
creo so we we have we provide we are
providing the API so that the onboarding
of all these applications is going to be
extremely easy when they somebody comes
onto our platform and third things from
a deployment standpoint what what you
would see today that many of these
enterprises just because of the dole
whole data security pieces they do not
want to deploy that on to the public
cloud
okay so cloud which is open to others so
so for us it was important that we
provide all the both the deployment
scenario is that whether they want to
deploy it on Prem or deploy it on the
cloud we kind of facilitate both of it
and the results that we have seen has
been extremely extremely good okay and
on back of it like for example um if you
take a standalone microsoft hololens
device which is considered to be the
best in class right now when it comes to
the AR glasses the maximum is the
maximum polygon that you can actually
run on those devices is 100k okay so if
you have something which is kind of
going to be bigger than that all that
you have to do okay you have to kind of
optimize and decimate it the right word
is decimate because you've got to kind
of remove that okay so and that's that's
a huge huge problem for for a lot of lot
of companies particularly in the
enterprises well there is a reason why
the models are created which that
fertility you know so but with using our
platform you can with a single GPU we
can actually scale up to like 50 million
poly 15 million poly complexity of
models can run using using our out
architecture using a single GPU and if
you are more if you want to run hundreds
and 100 or 200 million poly all that
we've got to do is kind of spawn few
more GPUs to kind of enable those
experiences 60 frames per second still
kind of used a yardstick because most of
the displays that will see the
60 frames per second that's a device
constraint that we have to work with
motion to photo latency latency you want
to ensure it's a sub 20 millisecond
motion two photon latency in terms of
augmented reality and virtual reality
like for people the motion for so the
whole thing is about if I take an action
and I move my head the scene that has to
kind of move within the sub 20
millisecond that's the from my motion to
the photon though the view has to be sub
20 millisecond and today from the
network even if your computer is like
sitting 40 milliseconds away we can
still bring down the perceptible delay
which is the motion to vote on leading
to sub 20 millisecond because we're
using a lot of that predictive
predictive algorithms caching there's a
whole bunch of different techniques that
we are using to kind of do this 3d
spatial mapping today like the devices
kind of map at 1 frames per second
because we are not constrained from a
computer standard we can do it
absolutely 60 frames per second which
allows us to have much more fine-grained
you know create the fine grain messes
which then we can actually use it for
more precise rendering so we can overlay
the virtual objects on a physical world
in a much much precise way almost to a
millimeter precision than any of the
current state-of-the-art devices could
do it yeah so this this is all from a
technology performance and part of it
like where is it being used the question
is like ok it's it's it's awesome that
we're getting some technology in place
but where is it being used actually for
most people the bleach had always had
been gaming like when it came to VR VR
kind of was pretty much led by the whole
gaming thing ok but when you come to a
are actually it's primarily is being
driven by the enterprise use cases and
and the use case it's it's no more the
use cases are no more in like mmm
experimental phases
actually getting deploy okay when I talk
about so so most of the use case is like
the design and engineering where let's
take specifically for a car design when
you're doing a designing of the car
earlier you used to use the the four
models or the clay models who kind of
create those models textures and overlay
and all that was kind of happening today
that is being almost replaced by the by
a are where you can now you can create a
physical form model to build start with
but all the iterations that whether I
will change the dashboard I want to kind
of overlay the different grille or the
or the the rearview mirror so you can
keep those either a Shahnaz as quickly
almost like real-time you can do that
which the that design which used to kind
of take almost months to complete now
you can actually do that in days on the
and on the operation and manufacturing
side so there is a the with with the air
glasses actually the level one employees
are being a is out of performing level
three employees so there's a huge jump
in the productivity or the efficiency
with which they can do this training
like I mean a training has been has been
an absolute success all the Walmart all
the employees with today join Walmart
actually are mandated to go through the
VR training today consumer experiences
like I think if you happen to get an
opportunity to go at any of the re
retail stores they have those VR
experiences there where you can actually
customize your car the way and then just
get into VR and just you see the car
what what you need and even in the VR
environment you take it on a drive to a
mountain or SC depending on what what
what what kind of a person what you
fancy there so today like that's going
to be the deployment where the
automotive aerospace and industrial
which is kind of picking up in a big way
so that's why we are focusing but we are
keeping an eye on the consumer use cases
we believe the most of the people are
going to be in
used to the two VR&E are through work
and that will kind of help even propel
the the consumer adoption the certain
future trends which will further kind of
help in proliferation of the demotion
medium 5g is definitely one of the big
pieces just having a conversation just
before we came here that today okay the
compute part is taking care what K what
about the bandwidth I the file G will
unlock some of those problems so you're
going to have further lower latency then
back through port you're going to use
the spectrum in a much much better way
as I said the enterprise use cases is
going to kind of propel many of the
adoption the consumer AVR and also there
is a we believe that there's a big scope
for the peer to peer network we're like
just think of it any device at your home
you add you almost you're creating your
own virtual cloud that's something that
is going to happen so that any device
within your in in your in your house is
is can use the computer of any other
device which is sitting idle I mean that
and those things are going to kind of
also help in a big way the whole concept
of the immersive thing using those
computer just sitting idle so that's it
from my side for now I'm happy to kind
of address any other questions which are
there I'm happy to chart after the end
of the session thank you very much
while you're standing here ok I'm
changing slides I want to ask you is one
of the reasons why a are and VR has not
been deployed more because of kind of
user fatigue no so so they're much there
are multiple things which are there um
obviously the one of the one of the
thing is the price point many of them
for from a device standpoint the price
point is also a big deterrent
and the the fatigue part that you are
talking about is has lot to do with the
fertility because see the human eye that
who does the feeling of nausea when you
are actually wearing a air or we are
glass has a lot to do with your body
feeling as if you were being poisoned
it's exact reaction to you you you
you've been kind of food poisoning or
something you start feeling nausea and
that part has got to do with the
fidelity not matching the real world it
would be more about the resolution like
16 K at like for like 90 frames 120
frames per second okay where the day as
long as mind is not able to detect that
the you are being kind of gained you
know it's if it is not able to
distinguish okay the real world in the
virtual world
you're not going to feel the fatigue and
the year and that will go with what
we're talking about okay yeah great
thanks so why don't you have a seat and
thank you will ask you to give your
comments and we will all have a
discussion let's put it off until after
the next set of comments thank you
when I was a research engineer back at
Bosch I used to come here often to
attend similar talks so I'm actually
quite chuffed to be here alright so a
brief introduction charter I promise
I'll try to make it short charter is a
large cable mass media company we we go
in our footprints by the name of
spectrum and so we have about 28 million
customers across 41 states in the US and
we have 98 thousand employees so some of
the key points I want to hit on today so
taking a slightly different point of
view not contrary you know I'd say but
slightly different point of view then
dija is you know one introduced
immersive
as a form of entertainment potentially I
want to hit upon the fact that you know
there are some technical challenges and
DeJong touched on most of them the cost
of computer does need to be resolved we
can help service providers can help it
is also a hard problem but it can be
solved and finally we think our equation
or simple math equation is bandwidth low
latency in compute should give us
superior experiences okay so in
introducing immersive just as an
extension of video you look to the
streaming video today there is no
interactivity all the content is
pre-loaded apply bandwidth you know with
HD even 4k 15 to 25 megabits per second
latency yes it does you know if you have
too much latency and too much error on
the network then obviously you'll see
some artifacts but generally very
tolerant to let me see it doesn't create
the whole motion two-photon experience
loop so far more tolerant and special
compute at the client display no we all
use you know hardware decoder that's in
our phones or anywhere else for that
matter a cloud gaming so this is
basically where the content starts get
getting rendered on the fly so you've
got basically all your game controller
input you're mashing your controller so
I'll going up in the cloud it's
rendering frames and it's bringing them
that back down and that loop needs to
happen at a rate at which you don't
perceive the lag so you know there are
there are many many articles written
about the subject we're going with 50
milliseconds latency you might find
another place that says 80 millisecond
latency you might find another place
that says 30 millisecond latency right
so but you know we think based on some
of the field trials that we've run you
know 50 milliseconds latency is it's a
pretty good estimate of the round-trip
loop and then of course there's compute
involved
you know there's an interesting
statistic that says that you know the
the content keeps outpacing the the
devices and so you know developers have
these unique challenges either they can
develop to all the devices and basically
deliver cartoonish content or they can
develop really bespoke content but then
it's only available on you know a
full-fledged PC with a vipro hmd for
example or an oculus rift and then last
but not the least we do actually believe
in this feature so you know I'm gonna go
back and add my two cents to one of the
things that was discussed towards the
end here between you Richard and DJ um
there's of course fatigue there's of
course the lack of retinal grade
resolution but one of the things that
has been said about AR and VR is it can
be an isolating experience especially
when you look at it as a form of
entertainment because when you like to
be entertained
you know you sometimes want to be with
friends right so you can argue that yes
now I can do this in my virtual living
room with other friends who are far away
so in that sense it's not isolating but
then with regards to your own family it
might feel really weird right so again
two-photon latency kicks in you
know things like like fields sometimes
are not about latency at all
they're about pure bandwidth trying to
render like 50 hundred different
perspectives all at the same time so
that you know whichever perspective you
take into looking into the light field
you know you without going through the
motion to photon latency loop you know
you get your your image your view some
challenges related to virtual reality
and augmented reality as we see it
I think the jam has been through most of
this you know high cost of pcs to
deliver what I would call premium
experiences you know you've got the
download to go watch a 360 video kind of
stuff but I think people who get
introduced to VR that way you know do
not really enjoy it
so then the second thing is you know all
this fragmented content and you know the
battles that go on in the market
augmented reality once again I think
DeJohn pointed to both of these and you
know the high price of hm DS so this is
what I would call sort of the virtuous
circle so what is the problem
today as you know we touched upon
earlier is this price point right you
gotta buy a $2,000 computer then you
gotta buy a $400
I'd have to say 400 now today with the
rift s so you know you're looking at a
fully-loaded price of 2500 to access a
premium experience or they're about
maybe 2000 you know maybe you get a good
deal right so so you know the challenges
of users are should I invest in this you
know I've got I've got limited content
I've got a high price of HMD you know at
the same time the developers are like
what's the point of making VR content
what's the point of making air VR
content because you know it does
I can't monetize it right and and then
the hmd guys are like I really need
scale so that you know I can bring down
the price points of my hm DS so what
needs to happen in this market is that
the virtuous growth cycle needs to be
stimulated how can network service
providers help we think that if we embed
compute in the network we may be able to
jumpstart this virtuous cycle once
you're able to take some of that compute
out then you can deliver those premium
experiences on you know low-power HMDs
that don't heat up you know that have
good form factors that essentially leads
to more people buying you know
developers earn more money all the tools
improve content gets less fragmented as
the industry matures
so a long time back I think I stole this
statement from a Sun Microsystems John
gage the network is the computer and I'm
adding my own twist to it because the
network will be the computer again so to
the left is basically you know proven
artifacts that GPUs can be migrated to
the cloud to deliver cloud gaming ham
and you've all heard of stadia of course
some of the early reviews have been a
little rough but we invested in 2018 in
a company called blade shadow which does
something similar but different in many
ways but essentially it's a cloud gaming
solution it has been proven to
essentially work under certain
constraints and it is indeed a proximity
based solution so that's really the the
one of the constraints you know you got
to think about some kind of an edge that
edge is not your local last mile that
can be far away so all of this followed
by a RvR and so these the streaming
content as it develops you know service
providers may choose and to find the
business case profitable to start moving
compute from national data centers to
regional data centers and then back down
to the edge data centers and then last
but not the least you know as you start
seeing more and more light fields but
displays clients that demand demand more
and more from the network then you know
bandwidth latency and all of those
things evolve along with the computer so
this is one of our ecosystem building
activities this year earlier we founded
the idea or the immersive digital
experiences Alliance I highly encourage
you guys to go check it out at immersive
Alliance dot-org
what are we doing we're trying to create
a royalty-free technical specifications
around the convenience
of immersive media and we generally do
education seminars and and we basically
curate new ideas and what I'm
specifically interested in the the work
group that I lead is the network
architecture work group and you know we
have you know huge spectrum of content
right you've got essentially raytrace
saying you know you got to run this on
multiple GPUs for X hours to render out
you know cinematic content and then
there's the interactive content which is
like can i virtualize my GPU can i slice
it and can i use it so you know there's
there's a huge spectrum and we're
looking at how the network could
potentially support all of these
applications perhaps in real time we
don't know whether we can do all of it
in real time such as you know ray
tracing and physically based rendering
engines but we're doing some experiments
and so this is some early curation of
ideas and on what direction we're moving
in which is that essentially you know in
today's world in the video world there's
an end-to-end flow that actually gets
negotiated end to end but you know what
we're looking at is can the network
actively engage can there be a quality
of experience attributes and client
attributes that help describe the
quality of experience attributes that
can then lead to the network actually
engaging storage and gauging compute
engaging its networking capabilities so
that the right quality of experience can
be delivered to the right device okay I
love this slide simple my equation you
know there's there's a delicate balance
depending on the application and the
quality of experience you know you need
to balance all of these three three
things you know there's bandwidth
there's latency and there's computer so
now I can finally move into edge
computing more as a concluding remarks
since I started with AR and VR so you
know I basically took these off of this
state of the edge to any 18 report I
highly encourage you to read
you read it essentially all this is a
set of use cases you know you've got
autonomous vehicles which is gonna be
you know ultra sensitive to latency and
jitter there's edge content delivery
which may be just about better video
delivery there's video surveillance
where you know there's a huge deluge of
upstream data video data there's a
imgine learning you know I already
talked about gaming and here we are and
then yes yes so according to me good bad
so great does it mean that all of all of
this is so there is no scale right
because none of these applications are
actually happened but it is someone's
attempt to try and put sort of an idea
of a scale without units on this so I
mean availability can still be measured
security you'd have to probably come up
with a serious metric to measure
security at the edge but the point is
kind of like how important it is for the
success of attributes yes exactly
this is really always this is somebody
else's rendition of what attributes
matter and in all of the edgiest cases
you know perhaps you know which
attributes like for example high
bandwidth and low latency is that what's
gonna go on or is it maybe not latency
sensitive like he says with video
surveillance not as latency sensitive so
so yeah I mean okay I am NOT gonna claim
authorship of this it is a rendition
take it for what it's worth
and that's it red doesn't mean yes
so latency is low and it's load to her
yes though is Louis by the definition of
this guy blue right whether it means
more resource constraint it by
definition still he has called it blue a
system with four autonomous vehicles
will have high bandwidth well will be
low jitter yes a very high availability
and also high yes so I appreciate your
thoughts on this slide for the first
time I was beta testing this one clearly
it could do anyway so I'll come to my
concluding slide ok so I do believe that
the network edge computing has a
potential to democratize AR we are and
other immersive experiences I'd make
slightly provocative statement here for
those of you who have been following 5g
which is that low latency high bandwidth
is probably a not probably is as as
certainly is a prerequisite to reap the
benefits of edge computing however its
computing is actually agnostic of any
network technology so you know if 5g
offers you you know in future if LTE
offers you 25 to 30 milliseconds latency
on the access network you know today
DOCSIS 3.1 will offer you something like
10 milliseconds then 5g will make it do
to 5 milliseconds and then you know we
have a path to 1 millisecond latency
over fiber so so there's going to be
some industry competition that is going
to be beneficial to the consumer to
drive Layton sees down and then last but
not the least this was a very
interesting report that came out again I
encourage you guys to take a look is
chapin sharma claims that the Internet
economy in about a decade from now will
kind of achieve the same scale and size
the cloud economy after day with mobile
economy so yeah with that I will
conclude yeah those are very large
numbers dijanna let's go to a showing BJ
BJ up on stage and you had a question
that I made you put off so why don't you
go ahead and ask I'll let you go first
even before me
device and egg and the cloud so the
question is how do we decide that when
we put what compute so so we have this
ability so any if you take any of the
immersive experiences there are
different tasks you think you can attend
you say one other thing I was talking
about was like the global lighting you
see whenever you see a the AVR
experience so there is a lighting shadow
there are many aspects many tasks which
are there and within that the aspects
which is more dynamic like which
requires immediate what I say a
real-time movement anything that
involves around that it has a low
latency budget so you need to do it
closer to you so like the global
lighting has a almost like a 200
millisecond kind of a budget so I can
have the global lighting done on them
even a computer which is father which in
this case could be a cloud if the cloud
is available to me within a 200
millisecond on the on the on the device
side because the whole thing it's we do
use the device as well as I was pointing
out that we know that the wireless
network is finicky and many of the
actions that we are taking is based on
the our prediction prediction algorithm
and end of the day the prediction is the
probability right it may not the solve
the prediction may not be correct and
then we have to reconstruct the whole
scene using the device itself with the
past data out of there's some caching
that we have done we know the past state
of May and and what is the position or
the you know the gauge of the person who
is kind of using it we can actually
recreate the whole thing on the device
itself so that's that's that's how we
can kind of do that and identify the
tasks and kind of run it at different
notes okay before before we get into
other audience questions
can I ask you real quick how much how
far along is grid last or how much money
have you raised sure yeah so we actually
close up close around very very recently
to point
million round Soviet per day is close to
two 3.2 million right now all together
and hopefully with all the engagements
that we have and and pretty pretty
confident that we'll have the commercial
things done
I think the coming year 2020 we
shouldn't have raised our next round so
is your model going to be licensed like
the platform that's the business yes
that would be the end goal where we
could be kind of it would be annual
licensing kind of a model we license our
technology and on top of it anybody
wants to run any use cases they want to
do so you're going to make an
open-source it's too early I'm putting
an awful lot of people I saw three hands
over here why don't you go first and
then you okay go ahead your first you
mentioned you need be to 22nd I agree
but then the rocker equally adds that's
what standard is being used
you know operators that I'm not aware of
a standard I know that for example Nokia
and Ericsson and where we are exactly
I'll make summarization so just
wondering in case whatever you are the
standardization of edge computing
architectures right but what you're
talking about the first one was was like
easy given practical because of yeah
real good body not the computer yeah you
know why so the way the way we do it is
just think of it the game logic kind of
runs on the on the server side I just
just to kind of give it quick answer to
that what we do as I said there's a lot
of prediction based so my network is I
sure like even if it's like 40
millisecond away what what what
essentially I'm trying to do here is I
am I'm running my game logic on the
cloud and rendering the rendering the
views and as the 40 to 50 millisecond
before even the user kind of does
anything around that and this is what
the prediction part of it is and if I
have kind of put that data already on to
the device or cash into onto the device
now based on the based on the you know
user position or any specific
interaction I can actually I don't have
to go back to the cloud to kind of show
that because I've already done that
I've already put it onto the onto the
device only places where my prediction
is not not able to if my prediction is
is not right and the user actually makes
a movement which I didn't kind of
predicted correctly in that case I have
to regenerate everything on the device
that's that's that's at the broad level
of what we are kind of doing and by
using that now how far that on the on
the network I can pool
but the computer has lot to do with how
much bandwidth that is available for me
it could be a case that I kind of
generate everything and put it on to the
device the storage that is required on
the device so there's the trade-off that
we are doing on that but today the best
mark that we have reached is like 40 mil
at a 60 frames per second 2k kind of a
resolution we can actually and if even
if it's 40 millisecond away we can
reduce the perceptible delay to some 20
millisecond and it has a lot to do with
the prediction algorithms that we are
running so to what extent is
standardization going to be essential or
is it going to be different from
application to application that's a DJ
quest so I wouldn't call anything
standardization right now I think we are
all in an ecosystem building phase and
there are some essentially I mean the
way I at least my opinion about
standards is when you know something is
so mature that you know it's not a key
part of the value chain and now you move
to need to move to the next level of
things that's when you come up with some
level of standardization and I feel like
this area is very very new that said
there are some good ecosystem and
specifications for example that have
come out of open XR which is more about
trying to make sure that this
fragmentation that is occurring between
compatibility of headset and content
doesn't occur in future there's a new
virtual link you know if any of you have
tried we are two laptops you've got all
these unwieldy cables so there's a new
virtual link standard which will have to
standardize the hardware interface there
and then in the idea group we are
looking at what what does a distribution
format which is 3d media native look
like so we just actually put out an eye
TMF immersive technologies media format
out there which basically specs a scene
graph and there are versions of scene
graphs out there like you know glt
opengl gltf which is a transmission
format and so on and so forth so we just
found some of the existing formats
somewhat inadequate so
our highly photorealistic rendering so I
need to ask a follow-up question before
we go on with your questions so neither
one of you mentioned an EVC which either
is mobile edge controller or multi
access edge controller yes and maybe
this is also a DJ question are those
something that the network is likely to
own and it may be located in a base
station are you thinking of you know
because you will also have a bunch of
truly mobile ones like inside
self-driving cars or connected cars
right right so I mean mobile edge
computing or multi access edge computing
to be more accurate essentially is about
you know assuming you have an edge it is
it is about contextual information
available to you all the time right the
problem with mobile edge compute or
multi access education is it doesn't
really address the more so immersive
neck is really addressed by guys like
grid raster mm-hmm and some of the work
we are also doing in partnership so so
I'd have to say that existing Mac is
highly inadequate to really address er
VR okay so that's another kind of
initiative that has to be done this is
some whether or not I work to be done
okay so I would also say this that you
know there are things that need to run
out of Etsy yeah because they link to
how you know the guys are gonna make
chipsets and so on and so forth I don't
believe it has been determined that you
know an immersive Mac necessarily needs
to come out of SC okay though okay until
somebody makes that determination so I'm
seeing lots of hands why don't you go
next and then you and then you go please
okay
all right can be tablets smartphone car
windshield or headsets the problem with
VR right now is the headset I have twice
$3,000 pull the lens one in to try to
get one with this kind of like but I
could only wear two $300 of oculus quest
I could only watch no more than 10
minutes because just like you say
there's fatigue and also the weight on
my the pressure the nose really I think
that's the reason it hasn't caught up in
the mass adoption and market yes they
are maybe because Apple maybe two years
cannot release their a are glasses that
is connected to smartphone not
independent until eyeglasses how many
years do you think that these will
become a mass-market mass adoptions that
we as developers can make money so did
John you had mentioned that Enterprise
is gonna be first
yeah right so I mean that's that's
something we kind of want to juggle like
think about every day right
just how do you monetize because the end
of the day the platform unless it is
used by somebody it's it's going to be
we are not going to make money right
what we are seeing is that the consumer
story has I think that a lot of
variables which needs to be kind of fall
in place like as you said was the device
and there's a price point and people
getting comfortable then you know then
the whole content the good thing with
and the reason week we kind of moved
from the consumer to the enterprises
precisely this reason that in
enterprises it's it's more it's more
value driven right
so for example I'll take the case of
mini aerospace let's suppose there is a
there is a there's the airplane that
something has gone wrong and it's
actually stranded and in one of them the
hangar some let's suppose in India and
let's suppose it's an it was the Airbus
Airbus airplane which was kind of there
now what is happening using a are only
ever used to happen the export will
travel all the way from France to India
repair it and then come back the whole
the cost of travel is insignificant that
what is significant is the amount of
time that that look in place okay and
that amount could run into hundreds of K
okay for them using a hololens which
even if it's takes like three k5k
it's still the value they will get out
of its to take humongous resumes where
people are wearing our headsets we're on
the early side of this what kind of a
time frame are you saying for a doctor
ai and industria are in the industrial
settings on the industrial setting a
while what I'm saying is if they're
already beginning to deploy okay so that
you would this is one of the customers
obviously I'm not able to rebuild I mean
they're actually buying to Orleans and
thousands now it's not only training for
even the manufacturing processes for for
hands on somebody doing and you get the
overlay of all the the models of the
steps instructions that you need to do
buying hololens in my closet when I'm
talking thousand is multiple puzzles now
that's that's what they're beginning to
use it that's that's the scale that
we're looking at so on the one side were
already saying there's an awful lot more
movement we'll have yet to see DJ what
do you think about the emergence
the side emergent experiences yes so I
mean if if you look at penetration time
or at least consumer stuff today I mean
depending on which report you look at it
somewhere between five and ten percent
greater five in eleven if you look at
work analysts predict in 20 so you know
if I out right now there is absolutely
no security very modern very minimum
coding most of initiative devices given
the complexity which should be more
secure why did you put it in the middle
because I will say it much further
because I act on these devices
much more senior absolutely absolutely
in fact if you talk to each other like
on-premise edge is the best edge so
these guys these are they want to build
in the next internet you know the ultra
low latency you know where so their
perspective is a little more consumer DJ
while you're on that are you looking at
say the development of these kinds of
architectures and other places besides
the u.s. too because I understand that
there's some you know two to five rack
mini-date Micro data centers being
constructed in some of the smart cities
in China
look I mean I've heard great news about
China heard great things about SK
Telecom in Korea yeah you know right and
you know so some of these stories are
actually you know you know excellent use
cases of how the word should do their
development that said I mean the u.s. is
a very large swath right I mean you
gotta run a backbone across the u.s.
yeah I mean it's crazy it's just it's a
huge land mass as you run fibre across
of it and then you take that code and
backbone and then you move into market
data centers and then you move into head
ends or what de Jong called central
offices for telcos and then you're
serving a few hundred homes on the other
so there's a lot today that goes on on
building a network like that but I think
some of the other insights I'd offer is
in places like Asia I think this is kind
of relevant to AR and VR is there's a
lot of location-based entertainment far
greater than the US that is actually
also cropping up so that's a very
interesting trend I mean in places where
I'd say cost of computing may still be
higher you know you're actually finding
you know some of these successful people
you know if you look at service business
model for example it's like you know
they just set up oh you know a reseller
of Servius content would basically set
up eight foot by 8 foot bays and the
same experience that a US consumer would
pay $3,000 for you know they would get
it in Asia in a location for I don't
know four pennies on the dollar I would
imagine so there's there's a lot of that
going on in Asia in the US on the other
hand these location-based experiences
are very jazzed up to some extent
there's a large segment of the
population there is actually not
experienced we are right in the u.s. at
all
because there's nothing in between there
isn't that you know eight foot by eight
foot base but I highly do encourage you
guys if anybody's not been to Dave and
Buster's
I think they were pretty good okay
looking at yes there'll be channel
partners they'll always be there and
Autodesk or Dessau systems they would be
like excellent from our angle what what
for us at this stage what it goes beyond
is whatever you're building it needs to
be used okay and that's where I think we
will be able to evolve the value in the
product so today that's that's the
reason the our initial customers that in
five or six of them that we are
currently working is all like directly
working with them okay and with that we
are learning like somebody is using
padishah Cree or somebody is using the
Autodesk or the the Katia models even in
the same organization people have Katia
and different for different purposes
different group use different purposes
so those are the things actually we're
learning which is more on the
integration side of it the product
ization
side of the things yes once we kind of
trashed that out it would be excellent
for for me to kind of take this solution
to an order desk okay Abby I can enable
you this with all your different plan
although all your different customers
who kind of require it like we are also
part of the the Siemens the frontier
program
they have which is again which kind of
pretty well kind of overlaps it does the
fill terms of the focus they're pretty
big presence in the automotive and
aerospace
I think 70% of the revenue come from
that so that that's that's something
that we are already kind of beginning to
start working with not yet but we did
kind of apply at some state so the the
the what is that statics forum but I
think there was I think it was two
preliminary for us that's all absolutely
absolutely
thank you other questions go ahead did I
hear you say the balance network balance
misunderstood suicide thing you use the
phrase balance network okay good next
question might have on especially when
you think about the streaming data yes
any development on the GPU on the FPGA
that that part of it only helps us you
know in from you're saying on the device
on the device
[Music]
away from the collection point certain
decisions have to be made in terms of
how data gets managed how it gets
distributed can I throw my own so you're
going to have all sorts of different
architectures right you might have a
factory if you're if you've got workers
going around with glasses they're not
going to have much on the glasses in
terms of a sort of the system board and
so it makes much more sense to have
something on the floor of the factory
that's kind of doing most of the
processing right there at the factory in
a self-driving car it's got to pretty
much be in the car and yeah I saw that
from Volvo and a few weeks ago yeah but
in any case you're going to see
different things it's not that one is
right it's getting the right fit for the
right business and that's going to be
where the killer you know kind of that's
why I was gonna do jumps framing the
hierarchical and field right so if you
have compute everywhere then based on
the quality of experience that's needed
you have to make some dynamic decisions
yes you know start looking into
I also like your point about edge being
agnostic of the network which means the
edge can go on and develop you don't
have to wait for 5g that's and I think
this too in some ways edge optimizes the
network infrastructure that you have but
it must be kind of scary for a telecom
company to think about the sort of
possible capital capital expenditures
that might be involved in having the
compute infrastructure to support edge
computing and that's exactly right right
so you've got I mean if you look at it
from a telecom companies point of view
they first have to get all the
connectivity and low mid high band and
then they have to get the computing and
I think for any operator which has a
capital intensive business this is going
to be a challenge I think we're thinking
about it
exactly I mean all of you so once again
go back to sort of the hierarchy of
computer analogy but I mean the way we
look at the network is you know if there
are access to your point virtualization
and software-defined network if there
are any of those latency critical
functions that are right around you know
five Mac or you know Radio selection all
of those will have to sit right at the
edge of the access network which you
know for a telco is a tower right for us
but if I can also kind of interrupt and
put a plug in the videos of most of the
previous sessions in this series are
already viewable online you can see them
on our website
Asia dot stanford.edu and they're free
total access the third session in our
program was from Intel about chip
acceleration and so you know that that
has been discussed in this series
already correct
well actually you've got FPGA you've got
GPU and increasingly you have Asics
because if you have large numbers of
devices then it becomes cost-effective
to design a mission specific chip for
that specific device and you'll always
be able to reduce wiring and reduce the
size of the chip and get faster
throughput and lower power so that
that's really a huge thing that those
chip industry is just delighted about
right yes I mentioned also that you know
for us we we talk in terms of converged
networks now so you know it really
depends you know depending on where your
act could be wired it could be Wireless
it could be a small so it could be Wi-Fi
you know so you know it's really about
you know where you're at and what's your
best link what are the things that
you're most worried might prevent kind
of what could happen in edge computing
what do you think are the sort of big
dangers on the horizon that
couldn't mess up this whole picture well
I mean I think I mean the edge computing
industry has barely started and so we
are not even hit what I call the hype
cycle just yet we're about getting there
right so today I don't think that we
have a traffic disillusion when quite
happening just yet so it's about getting
your decisions right it's about getting
your business cases right and I'm pretty
sure though in the future that we there
would be lots of things that would keep
us up at night but you know what I would
like to see is mass adoption of
immersive for me there's a couple of
things on the edge computing even so as
I was saying the reason that we went
after use cases based on value rather
than the the volume was because for the
volume to happen there are many other
aspects even from a computing standpoint
the GPUs are still pretty expensive GPUs
are still very expensive if you were
you're looking to build the kind of the
volume that you're looking at it at
those price points also has to kind of
come down and if they do not happen I
kind of money that will be required to
kind of put out that kind of
infrastructure is is going to be become
quite challenging so I definitely see
either the price part of GPU coming down
and that's going to happen consider
considering which some of the
information insights that we have and
the developments that is happening in
even like all the biggies are kind of
coming in there so that's definitely the
more you hear about it
the less riskier start looking and
that's how we just have to kind of
navigate ok great
I'm afraid we kind of have run out of
time we've got some refreshments outside
please plan on continuing our
conversations in a more informal setting
for now if you would please join me in
thanking Dijon
thank you